hello my name is markiplier and welcome
to the backwards action challenge I'm
here joined by Tyler team edge say hi hi
no you can't me so we're gonna be doing
the backwards action challenge which
means that we've got a phone full of
suggestions from you guys and some that
we made up on our own and we're gonna be
trying to act them out backwards and
whoever gets the best one gets a point
the points still mean anything we're not
gonna dally we're actually not going to
review anything so we're just gonna kind
of guess who was the best me pop yeah
anyway so we're gonna do that and then
we're gonna do something else and then
we're gonna you you'll see what it means
okay who's ready me sure we all have to
do these and whoever's the best is the
best but you have to be jumping out of
an airplane sounds or no Silas you could
sell sound away yeah well they have to
be back let's put that in reverse
carry low on this one ready
[Laughter]
all right you gotta reverse
[Music]
okay ready for this yeah everybody stand
back gonna be amazing
[Applause]
I take that in Reverse
[Music]
we come we come play rewind that giving
birth wolf taking off into space
[Applause]
[Music]
take that and rewind it back I got a
little twist here yeah
I wasn't trying to backward button to
Jenny the tag backwards female
[Music]
[Laughter]
winning Vega that you hit the jackpot
ecstasy no let's put that in Reverse
[Laughter]
[Music]
take that and rewind it back
okay
[Applause]
[Music]